peter you mentioned the texans durant
through the quarterbacks you know
a point that someone made to me
yesterday and it was good enough that i
stole it and wrote about it last night
on pft
the texans are now under even more
pressure to not screw up their hire and
they're all over the place hey let's
talk to eric b enemy oh wait we blew the
window to talk to him
during the bye week now we have to wait
till the chiefs are done who are they
going to hire are they trying to placate
deshaun watson
what's their vision who's in charge what
other changes are they going to make
they'd better get a good coach in there
because now you've got urban meyer
frank reich and mike vrabel in the afc
south
that the texans head coach is going to
have to match wits with twice per year
so
as the jaguars turn into a team
to be reckoned with the texans have to
worry about
falling off the map and the mere fact
that urban meyer is with the jaguars
making deshaun watson more determined to
get the hell out of houston
i mean we'll see i i you know i'm one of
these who
uh one of the one of these people who
i don't think it's over for desean
watson in houston you know i think that
you've got to give the general manager
who just took over
this position a week ago you've got to
give them a little time you've got three
and a half months mike
you don't have to make a decision next
week you don't have to make a decision
next month
you don't really have to make a decision
until
the day the first day of the draft which
i believe is april
29th and so you know i say
just let all of this simmer down the
water is at a boil right now let's wait
till it gets to room temperature
and let's wait till uh the texans hire a
coach
and on february 10th reach out to
deshaun watson and ask
if either at a very respectful distance
social distance we can get together the
three of us
and have a conversation and maybe bring
an owner who
uh you know deshawn probably has very
little use for now
uh you know because he thinks that that
cal mcnair ignored him uh in looking for
a general manager and perhaps a coach
but i just think that needs to be
soothed we'll see what happens i'm not
saying
it's going to get solved i'm not saying
it's not going to but i think to say
with any kind of certainty that desean
watson has played his last snap for the
texans
i just think is way premature my point
though is the texans got to make
a good hire at coach now that meyer's in
the division and
that higher is going to influence don't
take patience
by the way by the way by the way don't
you think now
in some ways that it really
it kind of increases the pressure on the
texans to hire
eric b enemy don't you think so well
because
honestly yes go ahead yes no i agree
with you i mean they've got to get
they've got to get this right
they've got to get things soothed and
their only chance of soothing it with
deshaun watson i think is hiring the guy
that he said go higher
right i agree totally and and look
look i don't care how it comes about
you know it's like when people say oh my
god so and so wasn't a first ballot hall
of famer
i can't name you other than the the
cause celebs like
uh tara owens i can't name i'm on the
committee for 30 years
i can't name you oh was he a first i
don't remember
you know you remember the famous ones
because people keep bringing up
but it's just like would anybody ever
remember
after eric b enemy uh you know goes to
the super bowl in his fourth year
with houston oh man they they screwed it
up they had to be forced into hiring
people would remember it but it would
become an old story
and in my opinion it doesn't matter how
you get a job
it doesn't matter how you get there when
you get the job take advantage of it
and personally i don't care you know i
just
i really very selfishly i'm sorry i want
to see the guy get a chance
i want to see eric b enemy get a chance
to be a head coach
because the you know he deserves it
period
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports